hey guys how's it going so it's been a
while since I've done sort of a little
apple news Apple rumour wrap-up video
but it's 2017 so it's about time we get
the ball rolling because before you know
it there's going to be an iPhone 7s
they're making new MacBooks at might be
annual I'm at their baby new iPad but
who really knows no one no one really
knows it's a chapel and people to post
fake news on the Internet so I'm all
about Apple fake news give me more of it
all right Larry did like a quick little
search to see I like to start at
MacRumors
before I go anywhere else because I have
been following MacRumors since it's like
probably day one of the internet 1012
for beta night shift mode developers on
a cool Iowa's remain a great enhanced
Siri capabilities for next gen phones
that could be cool it was interesting
when I was doing my 10 year iPhone video
and hearing series voice back in the day
how it sounded how it sounds now
significantly much better Apple speaks
up as he proved from the sphere just
wireless device with Bluetooth and NFC
ooh what could it be
don't care whatever it is I'll take it
fossil the device in question is
something that's used in retail Apple
stores such as a product display
wireless charging I come on can we just
look you've got to I absolutely love how
the Apple watch charges it's just you
just drop it right on beautiful you know
that's actually not wireless or still a
wire you know what I mean what's next
for macbook updated MacBooks introduced
in 2017 or expected for minor processing
pay alright so some updates what about
the MacBook Pro because I'm already
ready for an update which makes me very
very sad the nine point seven inch iPad
pro was a ten and a half inch piece of
paper over as an example of what a ten
and a half inch I've had might look like
I thought that was the screen I was like
well that looks great no it's a piece of
paper okay I love technology three new
I've had such a launch in March
including bezel free ten point nine inch
models who tell us more said all-new
three iPad pro model being quad
microphones compared to the current roll
camera good they'll still have the 3.5
millimeter headphone jack that is so
sweet of you guys
we more revolutionary changes ipads the
gluten push all the displays click 2018
tenderloin this video suck
there's nothing good I need some
information
I don't know the best release date ok
yes I'm looking for all the way of
iPhone 7s news here's where I'll find it
oh I hate everything you need to know
show me what you got the room is so hot
we've had to make a whole nother video
about the iconic 2017 what will it be
called as I got you can read me a book I
would listen I don't have an S design
all new all glass that would be going
back to like the iPhone 4 Oh God
shatter City now the key iPhone 7s
theory is that Apple will finally get to
the home button that will be kind of
interesting because I've been using Mike
nickels owns a lot and not having a
dedicated home button is kind of
interesting just when I started getting
used to having a software home button I
then go back to my iPhone and then I got
to push the little cent your home button
what I think I'll actually probably kind
of meant because I do like having that
sort of dedicated thing that I just know
is always there but you do used to
having it built into the software ah a
new ceramic design
oh yeah baby I would be slapped that
home is going to be so expensive if it's
at all ceramic phone like it's going to
probably be like I would say probably
like $2,500 now actually it might be
more I mean if the Apple watch ceramic
is a triple the amount of a normal one
then yeah I mean oh boy pricey that will
be an expensive phone the biggest iPhone
s room by far is that Apple will finally
introduce OLED displays today apples
retain the use of LCD panels
Samsung has been turning out a yet so
all the alphabet OLED for a while each
pixel produces its own lights that means
the screen doesn't need a backlight
which saves power very good because I
still carry around low fees like it I
feel like it is my job to carry around
mo fees because my friends now expect
that is they're out with me I'm going to
have a low fee and they can charge their
phone so that it is it's just a sickness
it's just my thing at this point I some
7s
so this is all like nothing but I don't
x4 iPhone 8 or iPhone 7 that's what
Wilma next act will be called I don't
know I thought I liked it I liked it
that's just going to completely ruin
everything what did they just decide you
know we're not going to hold the ice on
an iPhone anymore we're going to call it
so presumably through knowledge the temp
the university that would be create I
found it replaces touch ID with to a
factor fingerprint and facial
recognition I mean like what are you
guys most looking forward to like when
you are looking to upgrade your phone
with what is it that is something that
you're most looking for one of the
things I think that I'd be looking for I
use my phone so much like it has to have
better battery life
I think the OLED screen would definitely
help out with that and I watch a lot of
shows I do so many things on my phone
that having a better screen clearly is
something that would be a huge upgrade a
better camera the camera is already
great you can always do a little bit
better the front-facing camera still of
1080p and the audio - it's not bad but
it's not good especially in this version
I feel like there is buzz sounds that I
get when I'm filming with my camera the
microphone just doesn't sound very good
I think that is a case by case I phone
issue I don't think it's all of them but
for me it was so fly really don't film
too much on my phone wireless charging
please and if you could make it a little
bit thinner that'd be great at this
point I've already over the fact that it
doesn't have a headphone jack so clearly
that's not something that you're going
to go back to I've actually been really
enjoying my ear pods and I don't know
how this is possible but for some reason
the inner pods stand when I'm running
but yes I'm sitting still they fall out
I guess doesn't make sense
it's crazy this is interesting the ipad
the ipad console chooses the Apple
pencil - could also launch an accessory
for the iPhone and MacBook
as far as MacBook compatibility if Apple
has already been grazed in a patent for
a stylus that works on the Magic
Trackpad the track out of the room ok
yeah that would be great I tried that
opened up my macbook I was like can I
use I have a pencil on this track that
you can well that's it I hope there's
going to be more information out soon
something that we can at least talk
about but in the meantime I guess I'm
most interested to see what you guys are
looking forward to and I'm sure a lot of
you guys and I got Android get a PC and
come on now
we're talking about we're talking about
Apple right now B night I'll see you
guys in my next video I also have a
bunch of other videos that I posted last
week so feel free to check those out and
I will see you in the next one sighs I
hadn't really quick I still add all of
my own videos and I get things done
quite quick I'm pretty efficient
everything was lagging like I would be
five steps ahead of what I was editing I
was already made a cup deleted the
previous clip and no something else it's
new try to catch up